[Music]
welcome back to signs click today
Newton's gravity why does an apple fall
from a tree towards the ground and why
does the moon orbit around the Earth in
the 17th century mathematician and
physicist Isaac Newton answers these two
questions with a single answer
gravitation what is gravitation in the
universe all objects that possess a mass
attract each other for example the moon
attracts the earth and the earth
attracts the moon now let us imagine a
first object a and a second object be
separated by a certain distance because
of gravitation these two objects attract
each other in this way a will get closer
to B and B will get closer to a if a was
more massive then the gravitational pull
would be stronger inversely if a was
less massive and the gravitational pull
would be weaker this is equally true for
be following on if the two objects were
more distant the gravitational pull
would be weaker and if they were close
the gravitational pull would be stronger
as such the gravitational pull of one
object on another goes away when the two
objects are very far apart let's now
take the example of an apple the Apple
possesses a certain mass and so does the
earth so the Apple attracts the earth
and inversely the earth attracts the
Apple
this is why the Apple and the earth will
get closer one to the other
up until the Apple touches the ground
now let's imagine that we throw the
Apple in a direction with a certain
speed like before the Apple will be
attracted to the earth but it will also
move in the direction in which it was
thrown depending on its speed the faster
the Apple is thrown the further the
Apple falls now if we could throw the
Apple with a high enough speed we would
see that this velocity would counter the
gravitational pull and that the Apple
would never fall down on the ground this
is what happens with the moon and that
is why the moon orbits around the earth
as well as why the earth orbits around
the Sun
[Music]